i've been auditing the budget and i
noticed you're way behind on your
paperwork
uh jerry you haven't filled out a pc10
form
in two and a half years geez i'm sorry
but
yeah we kind of do our paperwork at our
own speech oh really well i kind of need
you to do it at my speed
fine i'll do them what is wrong with you
today did they cancel game of thrones
nothing is wrong just do your job
and they would never cancel game of
thrones it's a crossover hit
it's not just for fantasy enthusiasts
they're telling human stories in a
fantasy world
fill out the forms please thank you okay
that's good on places to live
let's go back to dream jobs but that's
the thing this is the perfect present i
just keep getting outbid by someone
named
tall tyrion lannister what kind of name
is tyrion anyway
you're kidding right tyrion lannister
lord of casterly rock
the half man you don't watch game of
thrones no
you do hell yeah have you seen those
dothraki dudes
they can get it everybody on that show
can get it
i think i know who i'm fitting against
stop
bidding on my waffle iron your future
mrs tiger woods
i made that profile like 10 years ago i
don't know how to change it the point is
i'm getting that waffle iron for leslie
for breakfast day uh
no you're not i'm getting it for her for
waffle date wait you have a breakfast
day too
mine's in june please ben this is the
celebration of the anniversary of the
first time we hung out at jj's which she
considers the beginning of our
friendship
well imagine being married to her it's
like being smothered with a hand-quilted
pillow filled with cherished memories i
can't believe i'm complaining about how
thoughtful my wife is
sorry honey i love you look i have known
her for longer i have
five years worth of anniversaries so i
have seniority oh god oh no we've lost
the auction
what no somebody swooped in at the last
second and now we're both
screwed no okay tyrion lannister why
don't you just
cast a spell and get us the waffle iron
back oh okay i don't even have time to
tell you how wrong you are
actually it's gonna bug me if i don't
the lannisters while very wealthy
do not possess the magical abilities of
say the warlocks of qarth for example
this is why we don't hang out
ben and i are weaving our lives together
so i have woven this quilt
it represents every member of our new
united family
of all my metaphorical art projects this
is by far the coziest
happy anniversary
[Music]
it's the iron throne oh it's the iron
throne yes
it is i had a guy at the model store
make a replica he's a bigger game of
thrones fan than you are
okay i know i'm making that dumb
surprise face but i can't help it this
is the greatest gift i've ever received
leslie
when you play the game of thrones you
win or you die
yes no yes
no come here come hither peasant come
here who are you
our starship is in trouble okay leslie
listen if you're not if you don't know
what you're talking about hi joan
hi my name is april and i'm your biggest
fan and i pretty much hate everyone will
you sign your ninth memoir for me
well it would be my pleasure you said
your name was glenn
yes i did that's pretty this is insane
okay let us out
oh my god babe game of thrones is on
tonight it's the series finale khaleesi
is marrying jack sparrow
oh god that show has really gone off the
rails look it makes sense if you've read
the books
hang on can you actually do this well
technically
only the queen can knight somebody but
i'm so rich that she lets me do what i
want
would you like to be knighted oh no no
no no no of course not it's andy's day
dude i don't mind oh then yeah snake me
please oh my god this is amazing
winter is coming for sir ben light
starting okay
you're both knights guys this was so
much fun
you